Attention cette vidéo ne va pas être très amusante bien au contraire mais j'ai besoin de la faire vraiment ça me fait du bien il
faut que j'extériorise des choses que je pense.
Hier je suis allé chez youtube pour aller chercher le bouton des 10 millions d'abonnés, il est ici voilà bravo
il vous appartient autant qu'à moi en vrai tout ça c'est grâce à vous. C'est juste un objet il fallait que j'aille le chercher
c'est un symbole, mais en fait c'est pas pour ça que je fais cette vidéo, c'est plus pour ce qui a suivi.. À
savoir hier soir j'ai posté une photo du coup, où je suis avec ce bouton, en disant bah merci quoi parce que c'est vraiment..
C'est fou ce que je vis c'est incroyable, j'ai une chance exceptionnelle, mais on va y venir juste après, et, ET,
ET, ET, sous ces post j'ai reçu des milliers, des dizaines de milliers de commentaires mais
tellement gentils, les commentaires les plus touchants, les plus sincères, et les mieux rédigés que j'ai pu voir de toute ma carrière
et ça m'a tellement touché, vous savez quoi je vous le dis en toute transparence, que j'ai pleuré dans ma bignoire nu... dans MA bignoire *rire*
j'ai pleuré dans ma baignoire
en fait je me doucher tout simplement et je me suis mis à pleurer parce que j'ai réalisé à quel point
c'est complètement incroyable ce qui m'arrive et je pense que un humain n'est pas fait pour recevoir autant d'amour dans la gueule
d'un coup comme ça, vraiment. J'ai besoin de faire cette vidéo pour extérioriser ça et pour vous le renvoyer l'amour parce que
vous êtes 10 millions mais quand 10 millions  m'envoie de l'amour moi je suis seul derrière et c'est de ça fait très bizarre vraiment. Je vais pas
passer des messages, vous lire des messages, parce que c'est des gens qui m'ont écrit des trucs très personnel et ça se partage pas
mais croyez moi c'est des choses vraiment pures,
sincères, et en fait ça m'a juste fait réaliser à quel point j'ai un
impact sur la vie des gens à quel point je peux les pousser à donner le meilleur d'eux mêmes à traverser les problèmes
à voir la vie du meilleur angle possible, en fait tout simplement et ça va vraiment j'ai vraiment réalisé ça hier j'étais
hyper lucide avec tous ces commentaires là et ça m'a fait un bien
exceptionnel même moi en fait ça m'a fait relativiser à fond
en fait vous savez sur YouTube on a toujours des phases de doute on veut toujours donner le meilleur de nous mêmes faire mieux faire mieux
que les autres aussi
On oublie, je trouve, que l'important en fait c'est juste qu'on fait voyager des gens, on leur fait oublier plein de choses, on leur fait
apprendre des choses, on leur fait passer des moments géniaux,
et tout ça depuis sept ans en fait j'ai vraiment reçu des messages de gens qui m'ont dit "mec j'ai grandi avec toi
quand tu avais 14 ans j'avais 14 ans aussi
et maintenant on a tous les deux la vingtaine et je continue à regarder ce que tu fait" je trouve ça fou de grandir
virtuellement avec des gens,
d'avoir bercé un peu leur adolescence, et tout. Je trouve assez incoyable et je n'avais jamais pris conscience de sa
j'oublie très souvent le passé je m'en souviens pas assez, et là ça m'a mis une gifle
monumentale. Donc j'ai pas préparé de spitch ou des trucs à lire, ou quoi
J'avais juste besoin de vous parler vraiment quoi, parce qu'en fait j'ai eu les dix millions d'abonnés et j'ai rien fait parce que ma vidéo
10 millions d'abonnés elle, elle est pas prête tout simplement.
Elle arrivera en juin
je vais la tournée en mai ça va être deux semaines de tournage ça va être fabuleux ça va être trop bien. Mais je voulais
pas faire une vidéo où je dis "eh ben elle arrive en juin à demain pour une autre vidéo" je trouvais ça un peu bizarre
du coup j'ai rien fait
mais j'ai quand même ce
truc de putain mec mais c'est quand même un cap de fou c'est quand même important d'en parler, de faire un petit point,
d'extérioriser tout ça parce que c'est beaucoup pour un mec de 22 ans que je me prend, je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte, enfin en
positif hein, mais ma vie elle est incroyable c'est n'importe quoi j'ai pas dû passer par des tafs
chiants et pénibles. Vous savez j'ai commencé youtube j'avais 15 ans j'étais vraiment très jeune
c'était beaucoup pour moi et je pense qu'à la base je n'avais pas du tout les épaules pour supporter un truc pareil parce que voilà,
on est une personne, on a une personne publique on est sous les projecteurs, on est jugé ce qui est normal bien évidemment
euh, mais on n'est pas forcément prêt à tout ça et chaque rencontres que j'ai faites, que ce soit des amis
youtubers, des amis tout court ou vous, m'a permis
aujourd'hui d'être ce que je suis
et d'avoir la vie que j'ai et je suis très content de ça. Vous imaginez pas en fait comme vous m'avez aidé à me construire
moi-même à un âge où
j'étais parfaitement instable psychologiquement
et où j'avais besoin de ça, d'aide pour me construire, et vous m'avez vraiment aidé sur ça et ça j'en ai jamais parlé mais je
le pense vraiment aujourd'hui je suis comme ça parce que j'ai vécu ça parce que vous avez choisi de regarder mes vidéos
parce que vous m'avez envoyé des messages parce que je vous ai croisé en convention parce que je vous ai fait des câlins
tout ça ça a aidé à construire ma personnalité et à construire ce que je suis aujourd'hui et c'est juste dingue.
Si je pouvais revenir dix ans en arrière et dire au petit Lucas qui joue à Dofus "mec
t'inquiète t'es un looser avec les filles
t'es un gros geek
personne te comprends autour de toi mais t'inquiète continue parce que dans dix ans il y aura 10 millions de personnes qui sont abonnées et
qui auront kiffé ce que tu as fait"
et ben franchement
c'est le petit Lucas il serait tellement sur le cul
il comprendrait pas. Et du coup ça changerait tout mon destin et ça se trouve je finirai pas du tout youtubeur
voilà j'ai pas à pas grand chose de plus à dire à part juste merci merci merci
je pensais pas mais ce putain de boutons du coup
c'est parce que je les ai reçus que hier j'ai eu un vrai choc de fou après la photo vous m'avez envoyé mais des vagues
d'amour mais mais j'ai jamais vu ça
mais c'est
incroyable c'est fou l'amour que j'ai reçu hier, ça m'a mis sur le cul et même là encore aujourd'hui ça continue et je suis vraiment
ému en voyant tout ça et j'ai besoin d'en parler
ok, j'ai besoin d'extérioriser mon petit coeur il fait "Lucas y'a trop d'amour pour un seul homme ce n'est pas possible de gérer ça
renvoie le
attention !". En tout cas sachez que depuis que j'ai arrêté
de me forcer à faire des vidéos, depuis que j'en fais moins que j'en fais deux par semaine au lieu de quatre
je suis tellement plus épanouie, mais vraiment j'ai toujours des petites phases de doutes des petits... Mais c'est normal tous les créatifs on ça.
Mais voilà je voulais juste vous faire un message sincère. Je pense que j'appellerais la vidéo "un message sincère", ouais c'est pas mal
Du coup c'est bien beau tout ça mais là c'est un peu que dans un sens ce que je suis en train de vous dire
c'est je témoigne juste de l'amour que vous m'avez apporté. Mais moi ce que j'aurais à vous dire aujourd'hui c'est juste voyez le positif
essayez de toujours voir le positif même quand il y en a très peu il y a forcément une brindille de positif, on peut toujours se
dire que ça aurait pu être pire
même quand c'est désastreux on peut quand même se le dire vraiment. Moi comme je vous l'ai dit, je peux vous donner tous les conseils
que je veux mais je suis pas légitime j'ai une vie jusqu'à présent
j'ai trop de chance, j'ai vraiment une chance exceptionnelle
donc
je saurais pas trop quoi vous donner comme conseil, parce que vous avez plus de vue que moi et vous avez probablement plus d'expérience que
moi, sauf si vous avez huit ans. Mais voilà concentrez-vous sur le positif accrochez vous à vos passions,
foncez quand on vous dit "le fait pas" eh ben dites vous "ah mais peut-être qu'il faut le faire du coup puisqu'on m'a dit de pas le faire"
mais c'est sur une musique ça, attend en plus j'ai entendu, c'est vrai c'est Orelsan qui a dit ça dans une musique ! Mais c'est vraiment ce que
je pense parce que je l'ai vécu ce truc-là où je veux aller dans une direction et on me dit non non non le fait pas
fait pas fait pas, et j'ai quand même fait regarder la chance que j'ai, bon j'ai eu
énormément de chance, il y a plein de gens qui sont allés dans la même direction et qui n'ont pas eu le même parcours que moi
qui ont eu moins de chance et ça n'a pas marché pour eux, et
c'est triste, mais voilà faites ce qu'il faut pour être heureux concentrez-vous sur le positif et
envoyez de l'amour à vos proches aux gens qui vous entourent,
entourez-vous bien de bonnes personnes.
Il y a beaucoup d'enculés dans ce monde, mais il y aussi beaucoup de bonnes personnes on a tendance à l'oublier et à voir que
le négatif
et ça je vous dis je les ai vécu pendant des années, à voir que négatif, mais aujourd'hui j'arrive à voir vraiment que le positif
et puis voilà je pense pas que j'ai beaucoup d'autres trucs à dire. De toutes façon j'avais rien préparé je suis allé à l'arrache mais
j'en profite. Je fais pas beaucoup de vidéos où je parle comme ça. Est-ce que j'ai autre chose à dire ?..
bah non
Bah non je crois que c'est bon. Ah ça fait du bien. Ah ça fait du bien, j'ai bien fait, je suis content ! *rire*
Plein de bisous à vous, portez vous bien, passez un très bon week end. On se retrouve dimanche pour une prochaine vidéo et
j'espère que cette vidéo là vous aura pas trop fait chier, et puis si c'est le cas bah mettez un pousse rouge hein, y'a pas de problèmes
je vous fais des bisous, à très vite. Au-revoir tout le monde
*musique nostalgique*